Stephen Hawking was one of the most
influential scientists of his generation
from black holes through Simpsons his
impact on science and popular culture is
hard to overestimate in this video we're
going to look at just three publications
that shaped his career
number one the singularities of
gravitational collapse and cosmology
this paper was published in 1970 it was
a time when physicists were still
finding some of the implications of
general relativity hard to swallow
in particular the possibility of black
holes and infinitely dense singularities
Hawking and others had already shown
that singularities should form at least
in an abstract mathematical setting in
fact in his PhD thesis Hawking had
explored how the universe itself might
have originated from a singularity at
the beginning of time but in the 1970
paper Hawking worked with eminent
physicist Roger Penrose and showed that
general relativity even in the real
world really does predict singularities
number two black hole explosions as time
went on Stephen Hawking's name would
become inextricably linked with black
holes this paper really was called black
hole explosions with a question mark he
has a knack for grabbing people's
attention it describes what came to be
known as Hawking radiation which many
physicists regardless his most important
legacy Hawking was trying to reconcile
two seemingly incompatible theories one
was general relativity which works well
for describing the largest scales in the
universe
the other was quantum theory which
describes the smallest scales
[ __ ] realized that if you believe
both theories the event horizon or black
holes should emit radiation he had shown
that black holes are not actually black
to this day
physicists continue to argue over the
implications of Hawking radiation and in
particular about whether it raises
information from the universe which
would violate quantum theory and finally
number three a brief history of time
this is not a scientific paper but
rather a popular science book and it is
this book which would catapult Hawking
from prominent scientists to probably
the most famous scientist of his time
it gave him a new platform as a science
communicator a spokesperson and a
cultural phenomenon ever since people
around the world have been fascinated by
his story his intellect and his tenacity
many now know Stephen Hawking for his
characteristics and Teddy points his
appearances on television shows or his
controversial opinions on a whole host
of issues from a pie through to any life
but behind the pop-culture icon there
was a scientist whose legacy will endure
and as Hawking himself once said I hope
I will be remembered for my work on
black holes and the origin of the
universe not for things like appearing
on The Simpsons
you